>> Sean: WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
BUCKLE UP.
AN AVALANCHE IS COMING.
I HAVE BEEN TELLING YOU ABOUT
THIS.
IT WILL DESTROY IF THIS IS ANY
REMAINING CREDIBILITY OF THE
TINFOIL HAT CONSPIRACY THEORY
AND THE RAGE MEDIA MOB AND THE
HATE TRUMP LEFT AND THOSE WHO
ABUSED POWER INSIDE AND OUTSIDE
OF GOVERNMENT, YOU ARE ABOUT TO
FACE THE JUSTICE MANY OF YOU
DESERVE.
WE MADE A PROMISE ON THIS
PROGRAM WE WILL HOLD ALL OF THEM
ACCOUNTABLE WHICH IS A CENTRAL
FOCUS OF THIS SHOW.
TONIGHT WE ARE MAKING REAL,
SIGNIFICANT PROCESS ON MULTIPLE
FRONTS.
WHAT WILL HAPPEN IN THE DAYS AND
WEEKS AHEAD IS THIS WILL BE A
SHORT LIST OF WHAT WILL BE MADE
PUBLIC BEYOND THE MUELLER
REPORT.
SO MUCH MORE THAT IMPROVES THE
INVESTIGATIONS GOING ON FOR OVER
2 YEARS WILL BE PROVEN TO BE
TRUE THAT THIS SHOW HAS BEEN
CORRECT ALL ALONG.
THE MEDIA DEMOCRATIC MOB LIED TO
YOU FOR 2.5 YEARS.
A SHORT LIST OF WHAT WILL BE
MADE BUBBLE.
-- PUBLIC.
THE JUDICIAL WATCH RELEASED
TODAY.
IT'S BLOCKBUSTER.
CRIMINAL REFERRALS THIS WEEK BY
NUNC.
NUNEZ.
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR PLEDGING
AN INVESTIGATION.
-- THE REPORT ON FISA ABUSE AND
THE REPORT ON LEAKING CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION.
AND THE RELEASE OF MORE CLOSED
DOOR TESTIMONY THANKS TO
CONGRESSMAN COLLINS.
WE HAVE MORE TONIGHT WE WILL
SHARE.
VERY BLOCKBUSTER THERE.
ALSO FISA APPLICATIONS.
GANG OF 8 MATERIALS.
THEY ARE ALL COMING OUT.
AND ALSO THE UKRAINE ISSUE WHICH
IS SURFACES.
-- SURFACING.
GOING TO THE DOORSTEP OF JOE
BIDEN.
IT WILL COME CASCADING DOWN ON
THOSE PEOPLE WHO  ABUSED THEIR
POWER LINE.
BILL BARR WAS THERE TO TALK
ABOUT THE BUDGET BUT THE
CONVERSATION TURNED TO THE
MUELLER REPORT.
AND THE TRUMP RUSSIAN COLLUSION
WAS A GIANT HOAX.
WE HAVE THE FBI 9 MONTH
INVESTIGATION AND BIPARTISAN
SENATE INVESTIGATION AND THE
WORDS ARE CLEAR.
THE MUELLER INVESTIGATION, EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THESE
INVESTIGATIONS, YEAH, SAY THERE
WAS NO RUSSIAN COLLUSION
WHATSOEVER.
NONE.
THEY ALL IN THE MEDIA MOB GOT IT
WRONG.
NOW SHIFTING TO NEW CONSPIRACY
THEORIES.
WE WANT DONALD TRUMP'S TAXES.
MAYBE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IS
COVERING UP PHANTON CRIMES
HIDDEN DEEP WITHIN THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL FULL REPORT.
EVEN THOUGH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
SAID IT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
YOU CAN WATCH RACHAEL.
THEY ARE LYING TO THEIR VIEWERS.
"WASHINGTON POST" AND THE "NEW
YORK TIMES" NOT MUCH DIFFERENT.
PUSHING ARTICLES PAC
PUSHING ARTICLES BAC
PUSHING ARTICLES BASED ON HEAR
SAY.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TESTIFYING
THAT THE FULL REPORT WILL BE
RELEASED WITHIN A WEEK.
NO REQUEST FROM EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE BY THE PRESIDENT HAVE
BEEN MADE.
THE ONLY REDACTIONS WERE BASED
ON STRICT LEGAL GUIDELINES LIKE
NOT GIVING AWAY SOURCES OR
METHODS.
YOU CAN'T GIVE OUT GRAND JURY
INFORMATION.
>> I IDENTIFIED 4 AREAS THAT
SHOULD BE REDACTED.
THE FIRST IS 6-EMATERIAL.
THE SECOND IS INFORMATIONS THAT
WOULD REVEAL INTELLIGENT SOURCES
AND METHOD.
THE THIRD ARE INFORMATION IN THE
REPORT THAT COULD INTERFERE WITH
ON-GOING PROSECUTION.
AND INFORMATION THAT IMPLICATES
THE PRIVACY OF PLAYERS WHERE
THERE IS A DECISION NOT TO
CHARGE THEM.
FROM MY STANDPOINT.
WITHIN A WEEK, I WILL BE IN A
POSITION TO RELEASE THE REPORT
TO THE PUBLIC.
>> Sean: WE KNOW THERE WAS NO
COLLUSION OR OBSTRUCTION AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS NOTHING TO
HIDE.
THE SAME CAN'T BE SAID FOR THE
FBI OFFICIALS RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE WITCH HUNT AGAINST THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
TODAY MAJOR NEWS THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL BARR VOWING TO HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE.
THIS IS KEY.
WHAT THE HILL'S JOHN SOLOMON IS
CALLING THE SINGLE SENTENCE
RUSSIA BOMBSHELL THAT BARR
DELIVERED TO THINK  CONGRESS
TODAY THAT FEW IN THE MEDIA
PICKED UP ON.
-- THIS IS CRUCIAL.
>> THE OFFICE OF THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL HAS A PENDING
INVESTIGATION OF THE FISA
PROCESS IN THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION.
I EXPECT THAT WILL BE COMPLETE
IN PROBABLY MAY OR JUNE I AM
TOLD.
GENERALLY, I AM REVIEWING THE
CONDUCT OF THE INVESTIGATION.
AND TRYING TO GET MY ARMS AROUND
ALL OF THE ASPECTS OF THE
COUNTER INTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION CONDUCTED DURING
THE SUMMER OF 2016.
>> Sean: AND BARR WILL FORM A
TEAM TO REVIEW THE FBI'S ACTION
DURING THE PHONEY COLLUSION
PROBE.
DEEP STATE ACTORS WILL BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
CONGRESSMAN NUNES IS PREPARING
REFERSALS AND MARK MEADOWS SAID
MORE ON THE WAY BECAUSE OF
EVIDENCE OF ABUSE OF POUR IN THE
DOJ AND THE FBI.
WE WILL BE GETTING THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL'S REPORT AS THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL JUST MENTIONED AND THE
FISA APPLICATIONS AGAINST CARTER
PAGE AND THE RESULTS OF THE FISA
INVESTIGATION IN THE SENATE.
AT SOME POINT, WE WILL ALSO BE
GETTING THE REPORT INTO LEAKS BY
JOHN HOOVER AND THE 302'S, THE
TRIPLETS BETWEEN BRUCE OHR AND
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
WE WILL GET THOSE FROM THE FBI
AND THE GANG OF 8 MATERIAL AND
THANKS TO CONGRESSMAN DOUG
COLLINS, WE WILL GET ALL THE
CLOSED DOOR TESTIMONY FROM DEEP
STATE ACTORS.
THE EVIDENCE WILL COME CASCADING
DOWN ON THOSE GUILTY OF
CORRUPTION AND ABUSE OF POWER.
I PROMISE TELL DROWN THEM.
COLLINS RELEASED TESTIMONY FROM
JAMES BAKER.
REMEMBER HE WAS JIM COMEY'S
NUMBER 1ULAR.
-- LAWYER WHEN COMEY WAS THE
DIRECTOR.
HIS REMARKS REVEALED TODAY
BEHIND CLOSED DOOR TESTIMONY
REVEALS THE EXTREME BIAS AND
ABUSE OF POWER, IN THE HIGHEST
PARTS OF OUR GOVERNMENT.
HE WAS VERY CLEAR.
THANKS TO JOHN SOLOMON, WE KNOW
AND I EXPECT WE WILL HAVE
CONFIRMED TOMORROW, THAT BAKER
LATER TESTIFIED IN A DIFFERENT
CLOSED DOOR HEARING.
HILLARY CLINTON'S MISCONDUCT WAS
ALARMING AND APPALLING.
BAKER SAID THIS AND IT'S KEY, HE
BELIEVED THAT CLINTON SHOULD
HAVE BEEN INDICTED WITH CRIMES
AND THE ESPIONAGE ACT.
ALL OF THESE LIBERALS CONCERNED
ABOUT OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE.
HILLARY CLINTON DELETED EMAILS
AND WE HAVE THE TESTIMONY OF THE
JAMES BAKER THE EXACT DATE THEY
BLEACHED IT.
HE WAS TALKED OUT OF IT BY HIS
BOSS JIM COMEY AND OTHERS.
THIS TESTIMONY RELEASED ON BAKER
IS REVEALING WHAT IS RAMPANT
ANTI-TRUMP BIAS INSIDE THE
HIGHEST LEVELS OF THE FBI.
NOT RANK-AND-FILE.
WE HAVE BEEN RIGHT ALL ALONG.
THE CHOSEN CANDIDATE HILLARY
CLINTON GOT A FREE PASS.
A DUAL SYSTEM OF JUSTICE.
NO EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW.
TRUMP WAS PERSECUTED.
THEY WANTED HIM TO LOSE AND HAD
AN INSURANCE POLICY WHEN HE WON.
BAKER WAS ALARMED AND FREAKED
OUT WHEN HE SAW THE ANTI-TRUMP
TEXT BETWEEN FBI INVESTIGATOR
STRZOK AND LISA PAGE.
STRZOK INTERVIEWED HILLARY
CLINTON.
AND JAMES BAKER REVEALED THAT
HILLARY CLINTON'S PHONEY RUSSIAN
DOSSIER PLAYED INTO THE
INVESTIGATION OF TRUMP.
CLINTON PAID FOR.
IT IT WAS NOT VERIFIED AND THE
AUTHOR.
HE DOESN'T STAND BY IT.
IN OTHER WORDS, THERE WOULD HAVE
BEEN NO PROBABLE CAUSE TO
INVESTIGATE THE CAMPAIGN WITHOUT
CLINTON'S DIRTY RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
BAKER READ THE DOSSIER.
HE ADMITS PRIOR TO THE ELECTION.
THAT CAME OUT TODAY.
A PERSONAL RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
LAW FIRM THAT THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN FUNNELED TO THE MONEY
TO, TO HIRE FUSION GPS TO HIRE
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
WHO THEN USED PHONEY RUSSIAN
DIRT TO IMPACT AN ELECTION.
BAKER ADMITTED HE WAS THE
INTERMEDIARY BETWEEN PERKINS AND
THE FBI.
BAKER ADMITTED HE HAD CONTACT
WITH THE REPORTER DAVID CORN
PRIOR TO THE ELECTION ABOUT THE
DOSSIER.
HE SAID CORN A LEFT
WING-ACTIVIST WANTED TO GET THE
DOSSIER INTO THE HANDS OF THE
FBI.
COMEY'S NUMBER 1 LAWYER JAMES
BAKER KNEW ABOUT RAMPANT
PRO-HILLARY CLINTON AND
ANTI-TRUMP BIAS TO IMPACT THE
ELECTION.
THEY DID NOTHING TO STOP IT.
EVEN THOUGH HE BELIEVED CRIMES
WERE COMMITTED.
THAT SAME ATTORNEY JAMES BAKER
WAS IN CLOSE CONTACT WITH
CLINTON'S BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
LAW FIRM AND WAS FED THE DIRTY
DOSSIER BY THE MEDIA DESPERATE
TO STOP TRUMP.
THIS IS THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
THERE IS MORE.
BAKER TESTIFYING IN THE
TESTIMONY WE JUST GOT TODAY
AFTER TRUMP BECAME PRESIDENT THE
DEPARTMENT ATTORNEY GENERAL WHO
APPOINTED ROBERT MUELLER.
ROSENSTEIN WAS DISCUSSING A PLOT
TO REMOVE THE PRESIDENT.
AND ROD ROSENSTEIN OFFERED TO
SPY ON PRESIDENT TRUMP.
BAKER SAID IT WAS A SERIOUS
OFFICE  OFFER.
THIS SHOULD SHOCK THE CONSCIOUS
OF AMERICAN.
THEY TRIED TO INFLUENCE AN
ELECTION.
WHEN IT DID NOT WORK, THEY TRIED
TO REMOVE THE ELECTED PRESIDENT.
THIS DAMNING EVIDENCE SHOWING
RAMPANT ABUSE OF POWER AND
CORRUPTION.
IT SHOULD BE ON THE FRONT PAGE
OF EVERY NEWSPAPER IN THIS
COUNTRY.
IT IS NOT BECAUSE THE RAGE TRUMP
MEDIA MOB IS COMPLICIT IN A
MAJOR COVER-UP OF A DEEP STATE
COUP THAT THREATENED THE FABRIC
OF THIS GREAT REPUBLIC.
WE ARE FINDING OUT MORE
DEVASTATION INFORMATION HOW THE
DEEP STATE PROTECTED HILLARY
CLINTON BEFORE TURNING THEIR
FORCES AGAINST DONALD TRUMP.
THIS IS JUST OUT TODAY.
WE WILL BREAK IT DOWN FOR YOU.
THE FREEDOM OF INFORMATION ACT
REQUEST TODAY BORE FRUIT AND
FORCED THE RELEASE OF 422 PAGES
ABOUT PLATRIVER MET YORKS.
-- PLAT-RIVER NETWORKS.
ONE GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL SAID I
CAN SAY NOW WITHOUT RESERVATION
THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF CLASSIFIED
EMAILS IN THIS COLLECTION.
EACH VIOLATION CLEAR OF THE
ESPIONAGE ACT.
SHE CONTINUES.
I AM VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
RELEASE OF THE STATE
DEPARTMENT'S EQUITIES.
WHEN THIS IS RELEASED, THE
POTENTIAL DAMAGE TO THE FOREIGN
RELATIONS OF THE UNITED STATES
COULD BE SIGNIFICANT.
ADMITTING THAT FOREIGN ACTORS
GOT AHOLD OF HILLARY CLINTON'S
EMAILS.
THE FBI HAD AN INTERVIEW WITH AN
UNDIVEDED OFFICIAL.
-- UNIDENTIFIED OFFICIAL.
HILLARY CLINTON WANTS TO RUN FOR
PRESIDENT.
READING:
THE HILLARY COVER-UP OPERATION,
AND WORK TICKET.
AND THEY GO FURTHER.
THEY USE THE DATE THEY USED THE
BLEACH TO WIPE THE SERVER CLEAN.
THE OFFICIAL STATED THE COVER-UP
INFORMATION PROBABLY RELATED TO
CHANGE THE 60 DAY EMAIL
RETENTION.
BUT THE NETWORK DOWNLOADED THE
BLEACH BITS AT 11:42 A.M. MARCH
31st.
WHAT WAS HAPPENING?
OH THE DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES
WERE DEBATING TO GET THE
NOMINATION.
PERFECT TIME TO GET RID OF ALL
OF THIS.
WE KNOW THE EXACT SECOND SHE
OBSTRUCTED JUSTICE IN THIS CASE.
THAT WAS AFTER THE DELETIONS AND
THEN BEATING UP THE DEVICES WITH
HAMMERS.
LET'S SUM THIS UP.
THE FBI HAVE PROOF THAT HILLARY
CLINTON MISHANDLED TOP SECRET
EMAILS.
THEY BENT OVER BACK WARDS AND
EVEN PAIGE AND STRZOK ADMITTED
THEY PROTECTED HER BECAUSE THEY
ARE ALL DEMOCRATS.
THEY ACID WASHED THE HARD DRIVES
AND BEAT UP THE DEVICES WITH
HAMMERS AND THEY DIDN'T CONSIDER
HER CHARGING HER WITH
OBSTRUCTION.
IT WAS A RIGGED INVESTIGATION
BUT WE SPENT 2 YEARS AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP AFTER CLINTON
PUT TOGETHER A PHONEY RUSSIAN